as always our recordings of our virtual
meetups will be available on youtube
about a week after the meetup and we'll
post a message on meetup when the
recording is ready
so next i am very pleased to introduce
our speaker today
michael mccourt
michael mccourt was a chicago resident
for many years first doing undergrad at
the illinois institute of technology and
later some time as a postdoc at argonne
national labs
in between he finished his phd in
applied math at cornell and now he works
on sig opt from within intel as a senior
principal engineer
take it away michael
thank you very much rebecca for the
introduction uh and let me just say
again that i am very very very very
excited uh to be here
and in particular uh very excited to be
here uh as a member of intel
uh which uh is indeed a uh sponsor of
num focus and i definitely want to thank
uh everyone
uh at num focus for uh helping sponsor
this and and other projects which really
help build uh the competitional
community uh which is very exciting very
very exciting i'm very excited to be a
part of it and to see it continue to
evolve over time
i um
i have some slides here uh that i'd like
to share and in order to do that i think
what i'm going to try and do
is share
my whole window
and now
if i do
slide show
hopefully does that work rebecca does
everything look wonderful
yeah outstanding we see just the slide
we don't see your notes or anything uh
that's that's perfect i have no notes
i'm not a notes guy i'm just gonna go
for it we're gonna have some fun today
i've got some slides i've got some
jupiter notebooks i'd like to run
through
and uh hopefully have a little fun with
uh with this today uh please feel free
to ask questions as we go rebecca will
stop me
um i'd rather we make sure to answer
questions or if there are some really
crazy questions uh we can save those uh
for the end
uh let's uh let's kick it off as you can
see here the title of the talk is
bayesian optimization and related sample
efficient
uh which is a a sort of a
vague title in some ways obviously
basically that's very specific related
methods a very vague thing we're gonna
dive through uh some of the foundations
here and then stretch
stretch beyond what might normally be
talked about and think about why some of
these related topics are
important and exciting uh we'll see how
the time goes here rebecca if you could
stop me sort of with about 10 minutes to
go so that i know and so that
everything's in my mind that we're
pushing along fantastic thank you
all right
so
uh first off again uh thank you for the
opportunity to present
uh and thank you to the organizers so
chung rebecca uh sherry also sure i
don't think we've been introduced yet
but i know you're behind the scenes
making some of this episode thank you
um and so chung uh invited me to give
this talk and i've been friends for a
long time so i'm really excited to be
able to do this uh as part of
again staying a little bit close to the
chicago
community also quick shout out to the
qmc pie project which uh so chung and i
think maybe alexi is also here i have
spent a great deal of time uh working on
uh very proud of that project and of all
the great work everybody's been doing on
it so
shout out to that
uh personal introduction here exactly as
rebecca had mentioned uh before 2015
i was what i would call i would say i
was an academic doing just applied math
uh or computational statistics depending
on how you think about it a little bit
of time uh in new york but really a lot
of time
in chicago as an undergrad and also for
doing some of the research that i did
for my phd was at argonne
uh some time out and about some other
places postdoc at denver i was at hong
kong baptist university at various times
over uh
2003 to 2015 and then in 2015 big change
uh in my life did the transition to the
tech sector i sold out i became a a
corporate hack
at that point uh and i became a
particular sig ups as uh the first
employee in 2015 as a research engineer
um and it just so happened that
my research that i've been focused on in
gaussian processes and kernel methods
was really related to bayesian
optimization which gave me the ability
to contribute there but i'll tell you
what since i left to do the tech thing
to do the the industry life i really
love it i really love the opportunities
available to me the cool projects i get
to work on the amazing people i get to
meet and the fact that i still get to do
some exciting collaborations with uh
academics even though i'm no longer a
member of that community so it's been
really exciting uh we were acquired by
intel about boy 18 months ago now it's
kind of crazy to think about that uh and
unfortunately i don't get to do the fun
stuff anymore i don't get to do the
actual writing of the code or the actual
research so much anymore i just i just
managed but um but i still really love
doing it which is why i took a chance as
i was preparing this content to make
sure that uh i i did i did some of the
actual coding again and actually got to
put some stuff together so
um
quick outline of the session today and i
don't see my mouse so i'm just gonna
hope it's there i can vaguely see it
rebecca can you see my mouse is it
possible oh i can see it now maybe yep
okay all right very good very good thank
you uh so um first thing i want to do is
motivate sample efficient methods then i
want to talk about a very important tool
in modeling called gaussian processes
and gaussian processes are really really
really powerful they're exciting in all
sorts of different contexts in
particular they're exciting in this
topic of sample efficient methods and
then we're going to talk about how
somebody might do some of this stuff in
python same with bayesian optimization
which again is a very powerful tool in
this case that often uses gaussian
processes and how to do that in python
and then i'm going to talk about some of
these other methods that i have listed
here which are among this related sample
efficient methods topic show a little
bit of that in python and then i'm going
to show uh some use of sigops
to evoke some of these methods in
particular we'll talk some about what
sig ops is how it's designed and how it
uh gives people access to all of these
things uh without them having to know
all the crazy math sometimes that's
behind the scenes
um there is a github here and i i'm
sorry rebecca i should have shared this
before so that we could have posted it
before uh i will share it now
um in the hope that oh you know what
i'll share it at the end i'll show the
link at the end but there it is if
people want it so um i promise i will
give it to rebecca afterwards or i'll
give it at the end of the talk all right
so
uh let me start by talking about
non-sample efficient methods and in
general when you think about most
machine learning methods those are not
sample efficient methods in general uh
ml tools today
are
as powerful as they are and as capable
as they are because they have a great
ability to digest massive amounts of
data
uh the most powerful tools are the ones
that can effectively digest massive
piles of data for the purposes of
learning really complicated things
such as uh gee as i'm driving my
autonomous vehicle is that a car in
front of me or is that a person is the
car speeding up or is it slowing down
uh you know these are extremely
complicated problems that require
massive monday and here i put two graphs
in particular the one on the right is is
a common one i often think about which
is
showing uh sort of the size
of some of these neural networks as
represented by the size of these circles
uh 155 million
this is a very old graph i mean nowadays
they have even much much much bigger
neural networks but um
back when this came out i remember
thinking myself like boy 155
million
weights in your known that was a crazy
number of weights it's hard to even
think about that and yet these are the
standard tools that people are using and
the way that you can learn things that
have 155
million uh non-zeros 155 million weights
that you're using to try and learn
complicated things the only way you can
do that is with the massive amount of
data so these are these i'd say sort of
standard uh ml methods and in contrast
uh sample efficient
methods are methods which
either seek to make do with a very small
amount of data
or
and this is the main topic we're going
to talk about today
they try to acquire exactly the right
pieces of data in order to accomplish
some goal so instead of having uh maybe
a billion rows in your
data set that you're trying to study uh
maybe you have a thousand or a hundred
uh and some of what we're really going
to be talking about today is on the
order of a hundred or less
samples and trying to accomplish things
where you're going to be taking a
hundred or less samples and then the
question becomes okay what can be done
in that setting uh and in turn how do we
do it i'm just setting a
timer for myself so i don't forget
how much longer we have to go
um
let's uh let's push on here and talk
about what these sample efficient
methods are the names of these bayesian
optimization active learning active
search active differential inference
bayesian cubature and in reality the
presence of the words bayesian and
active these these could all be titled
bayesian active optimization bayesian
active learning bayesian active search
uh and in reality that's that's because
they all have a sort of very similar
structure and for those of you familiar
with the topic sequential decision
making
really all of these uh topics are part
of this sequential decision-making
framework so the main point that i'm
really emphasizing by talking about this
is that our goal when we develop these
tools or think about these tools is
often to use bayesian modeling or
inference to
actively drive whatever the desired
iterative process is and often it's it's
a learning process we're trying to learn
about the optimum or we're trying to
learn about satisfactory outcomes that
we search for we're trying to learn what
world we're living in through
differential inference we're trying to
learn an integral through cupature
unsurprisingly
so
the question then becomes okay that i
understand the goal
uh what what is what is this what is
this framework that we're talking about
here what are we trying to accomplish
and um
while i'm saying the term bayesian often
well i'm well i'm using fancy terms
about machine learning uh i want to
emphasize that these topics have been
thought about prior to posing them in a
bayesian framework i haven't put links
here but i put links at the end of this
topic to really emphasize the idea that
while uh it is very common to pose these
in a bayesian framework
the reason for that is not fundamental
the reasons are because it provides
convenient setup for the problem a
logical mechanism for saying hey here's
a model here's how i incorporate data
into that model
and and that allows you to to make
intelligent decisions in addition to
that and this is probably the most
important point the second one there it
it can incorporate problem dependent or
expert information to help improve
outcomes which again is very very very
important when we're trying to be sample
efficient
if i can
enforce my prior beliefs about the world
and greatly reduce the amount of data
required in order to build models i'm
doing a good job i'm happy about that so
if for instance i can impose information
such as uh the pressure of something
must be positive because that's just a
physical property or if i'm in i'm in
kelvin then the temperature must be
positive if i can impose that that can
help me maybe build models more
effectively more efficiently it also can
help with theoretical analysis but to be
perfectly frank i think most people who
do bayesian optimization only pay
a lip service to theoretical analysis it
doesn't mean it's irrelevant but a lot
of the proofs aren't terribly practical
in many circumstances for a lot of
reasons that we won't get in here today
though if somebody would like to know
i'm happy to talk about them later the
one thing i want to emphasize is that
for this session and even honestly
to execute on some of these topics you
don't need to be
an expert at bayesian modeling and
inference it helps
but i wouldn't consider myself an expert
at bayesian modeling in france but i
could still work on these topics because
they can be posed from a variety of
different frameworks so don't feel
scared when you see these words a lot of
fancy words here bayesian active
whatever cuba sure whatever yeah don't
worry we're gonna push through it we're
gonna see a few things and hopefully you
guys are gonna get the feel of the topic
and why it's exciting and uh if you want
to dive deeper i'm always happy to talk
about that all right
so this is the core structure underlying
this sort of
phasing optimization thing but then more
broadly sequential decision making
generally these methods start with some
sort of an initialization phase do they
have to no but you might as well write
it there because you could always say
initialization phase is null and that is
fine so in general we talked about there
being an initialization phase we also
talk about a conclusion
phase
and
um it may be something as simple as
saying and now i'm done or it may be
some additional post-hoc analysis of
whatever took place during your
sequential decision making process but
the the main thing the main sort of
rounded rectangle that you see here is
this sequential decision-making
iteration this loop that goes on whereas
with whatever data i have i build some
sort of model
using that model i identify what piece
of information would make me the
happiest in whatever i'm trying to
achieve and we'll talk about that in a
minute but there's some way to talk
about the next best piece of information
then i acquire that piece of information
then i build a new model
to identify the next best piece of
information acquire that piece of
information and this iteration here is
this sequential
decision-making loop that's underlying
all of these bayesian active methods
that's going on here now in reality
things can get crazy complicated i'm
talking about here as being sequential
but in reality it can happen in parallel
it could happen asynchronously in
parallel uh in addition to that this
topic of uh identify optimal next piece
of data incredibly complicated i mean
whole
uh you know millions of hours of
research get poured into this
question of even just understanding what
the word optimal means what does the
word optimal mean in different
circumstances i might even argue that's
a huge part of my job it's just helping
customers understand what they mean when
they say well i want it to be better i
want it to be the best
uh so so in reality um
keeping this loop in mind and keeping in
mind that we start by building some sort
of model we ask ourselves how can we use
this model to advance our interests and
then we advance our interests
that is uh the main thing that we're
going to be talking about today so
before i get into this topic of the full
iteration i want to spend a chunk of
time talking about this
key thing that we're just mentioning
here building the model
what is it to build a model
and in turn why do i have the word
gaussian processes on this slide and
indeed uh gaussian processes are a
popular tool for modeling they are not
the only tool for modeling obviously all
of us are out there building gradient
boosted trees neural networks uh or
maybe even just good old-fashioned
linear regression and those are also all
models
that one can build of things
those are all very useful models in
particular
the three of those are all very useful
models for situations where i have
massive amounts of data
but if you were going to try and build a
neural network on
five pieces of data i don't know maybe
you can i it's possible i'm not going to
tell you you can't do it but i'll tell
you what i think
the right tool is for these really
really small data models and i believe
in my heart they are gaussian processes
what is a gaussian process i'm going to
say what the definition is and then
we're not going to think about it
anymore the definition of a gaussian
process
is a stochastic process where
uh point
evaluations
of the process
have a
jointly multivariate normal distribution
with a defined mean prior mean and prior
covariance
uh in reality what does that mean well
we're just going to think about it based
on the pictures we see at the bottom
here
in each of these pictures i've got the
same five data points the yellow circles
represent function values the orange
bars represent uncertainty associated
with those values
as you see here a gaussian process model
is a model that tries to pass through
all of these points and in general
actually will pass through all of these
points subject to how much uncertainty
you have in your data
that does not mean that all gaussian
process models look the same they can
look like this over here or they could
be much tighter in trying to fit the
data which is maybe this model i have to
the right here or they could be a little
bit looser like we have the model here
or they could actually have no smooth
derivatives which is what this graph
that you see down here is this sort of
crazy looking brownian bridge style
graph
uh gaussian processors can have a lot of
different things happen but the reason
they're nice is that they work in
arbitrary dimensions i don't recommend
fitting a 50 000 dimension gaussian
process but you know they kind of work
the same whether you're in two or 20
dimensions all the way up to maybe 200 i
you get past 100 too much
in my opinion others may disagree
um they do require prior beliefs about
the desired model and the impact of
those prior beliefs is the different
models that you see listed here each of
these different models
has different prior beliefs about the
covariance and when you think about
covariance when i think about covariance
and in particular this topic of a
covariance kernel for gaussian processes
when i say covariance what i mean is how
does data that i've seen tell me about
data i haven't seen
and different choices about the
relationship between observed and
unobserved data will yield different
models that i fit and in particular here
uh what i'm saying is boy the data that
i've observed tells me very little about
the points that i haven't observed which
is why i have this crazy stuff going on
in between the observations that i've
that i've seen
and in contrast over here what i'm
saying is somehow
well the covariance that i want
is to yield the simplest model something
that that does as little as possible
uh and so that's why it sort of has
these very specific
small bands very little action between
the points uh and in fact i know that
this particular model that you're
looking at here has even a stronger
statement than that it actually says it
must
tag this point on the left and this
point on the right it has required
values that it's trying to achieve as
opposed to these other ones this one has
no required values this one has no
requirements this one is required to
take the value zero this one is required
to take i think it was the values one
and two or something like that so you
can have all these cool behaviors with
gaussian processes you don't need
crazier things than that necessarily
um we're going to spend a minute now
we're going to pop into a notebook to
take a very brief look at gaussian
processes in particular we're going to
look at this
frankie function classic function from
in my mind approximation theory uh and
we're going to talk about this gaussian
process posterior
mean and posterior variance and when i
use the term posterior again i know this
sounds fancy crazy basin whatever
don't worry about it it's just okay i
fit
points that i've sampled at these
locations to data observed from this
function
and my estimate of what's going to
happen
looks kind of like this which again
looks kind of like the function
this here is a statement of the variance
and that's basically an estimate of my
uncertainty how sure am i about the
model that i built where you see that
it's red uh that means i'm not very sure
where you see that it's deep blue you
mean i'm feeling okay about it and
unsurprisingly here i've got a whole lot
of uncertainty and my model's pretty
wrong
about that so that's not surprising
right all right let's pop into
our
notebook now and i see some chat do
people have questions i'm sorry oh no
she's already sent very good very good
thank you very much uh thank you very
very much very good so here we are we're
going to pop into one of the notebooks
that is available
uh in that
repo that i put together for this and it
as you can see just some content for
playing with gaussian presses nothing
crazy and you'll notice i've imported
just the bare minimum packages in my
opinion bare minimum i don't know maybe
you could write this whole thing
yourself just from base python but
please don't do that use the wonderful
num focused sponsored packages numpy and
sci-fi to do to do this kind of work
also matplotlib to visualize the work or
see born or plotty or whatever you love
it's fine um
i put here some math but honestly i just
put it as a placeholder don't worry
about the math too much all right we're
not going to worry about the math
i am going to say that the gaussian
process that i've created here
does have some fundamental assumptions
going along with it to just simplify the
code all right and what i really wanted
to show is that even though gaussian
process is a little scary i'm talking
about joint multivariate normal
posterior distribution blah blah blah
this is it this is the whole
this is the whole thing that's required
and you can see all this is just storing
the data
nothing else to it very very very small
you do a little cholesky factorization
of a covariance matrix that you compute
the covariance matrix is nothing more
than just these lines very very very
simple covariance matrix you'll notice
here
uh this is the exponential of r
squared
that should sound like a like a gaussian
in your mind that is the gaussian
covariance kernel other gaussian other
covariance kernels exist as well it's
also called squared exponential
covariance kernel uh and you know
computing the mean look how simple it is
very very simple it's just a simple
matrix vector
product uh i know it looks simple i also
know having done this for a long time
that there's some crazy stuff behind the
scenes there why does all this stuff
look like it does why does all of it
happen that's a whole other topic but i
just want to show you that it doesn't
have to be scary uh things can go bad
when you're doing gaussian process i
wouldn't pretend that they can't but but
in general things don't have to be crazy
uh here i've just created a very simple
function this is this frankie function
that we were looking at a second ago and
i've created some points on which to
plot the frankie function do a little
contour plot
and now we're going to take some points
randomly scattered throughout the domain
doesn't matter where they are
and see how it looks relative to the
function and you guys can see here that
that's really all i'm doing process
variance length scales observation noise
you're asking yourselves what are these
things
these are the so-called hyper parameters
of a gaussian process there can be other
hyperparameters as well in this
particular case i have simply fixed
these hyper parameters a little bit
below we'll talk about how these can be
learned
but in reality we don't have to learn we
can just fit them so just choose them
uh i don't recommend that in all
circumstances but for a simple example
here it's fine in reality we just
compute the mean and variance just using
this very simple computation we have up
here nothing crazy very very very very
straightforward but in reality are you
going to do this on your own
yay you can and if you're going to do
research on the topic you absolutely are
but in reality other people have already
done this stuff and you don't need to be
doing it so i've put here uh some
examples using the g pi and bow torch
libraries on how to do exactly the stuff
that i just did above so if you want to
follow this you can do this with these
nice wonderful open source libraries i'm
a huge fan of of bow torch uh
outstanding people uh it's based on g
pytorch which was developed at cornell
and uh some really great people at
facebook now called meta i have worked
to develop bow torch and it's really a
fantastic tool and i absolutely love it
so um if you see see it's very very
similar it's not exactly the same the
reason it's not the same is because
they're right here they're fitting those
hyper parameters that i just picked
personally
above they're actually fitting them
uh so uh they're making different
decisions this is not the same gaussian
process
uh but you see it's very similar uh and
um you can see here that i also have uh
done oh not g pi i'm sorry uh sk learn i
don't know why i put g pi i did sk learn
because uh sk learn is a num focus thing
not g pi so i'm sorry later on i'll add
a g pi example as to how to do it but sk
learn example on how to use uh the same
gaussian process regression concept
so
um
you can uh feel free to execute this on
your own if if you dare me i would i
would rerun the kernel but i want to
save some time for some other stuff so i
don't want to rerun this notebook it's
not a big deal though it's not nothing
crazy in here so
um
that is that is how i think about there
we go slideshow that is how i think
about uh the very very very basics of
gaussian processes like i said it can be
a really cool expansive topic or you can
keep it really tight if you want it to
be and we're going to be able to
actually get through
beijing optimization without going any
deeper into gaussian processes than that
now you may see terms like rbf
interpolation kriging ridge regression
discussed in literature feel that these
are all similar gaussian processes you
are right they are they absolutely are
very very very similar uh they're not
the same but they are similar i am more
than happy to talk about this but it's
just well beyond what we can talk about
uh right now so happy to talk about it
uh later on or another time
so what is bayesian optimization and i
hinted at this idea that sequential
decision making has this model next step
model next step model next step
structure here's what that looks like i
have a model of the data i've seen thus
far now i need to choose a next point
and i'm using sort of vague terms here
improvement
expected improvement we haven't defined
those yet but we'll get to it in a
second
i'm going to maximize whatever i think
of as the best thing i can do
and then i'm going to sample at that
point and when i sample at that point
that is this new point that i've
observed here
based on this new point i fit a new
model that new model kind of tells me
gee mike i think you should really
sample over here i would choose to
sample at the next point that's going to
give me something going on over here and
then i move on and i move on and i do it
again and again and again and again and
this up this iteration right here this
is the key to bayesian optimization fit
a model next point fit a model next
point
so how do we get this next point and the
answer is this word acquisition phrase
acquisition functions acquisition
function is a strategy for defining the
utility of a future sample given the
current sample and in general
acquisition functions balance
exploitation with exploration
exploration's the idea of i want to
learn about what's going on with the
function i need to know everything about
it exploitation
is the idea that
i only really need to know a very
specific piece of information to
accomplish what i'm trying to accomplish
right now and what i'm trying to
accomplish for bayesian optimization is
i'm trying to find the maximum
if there's a region of the function
that's full of terrible values
i don't really need to be spending much
time searching there that's the idea of
exploitation
and this balance between these two is
what drives the sequential decision
making process now as you can see here
we've got five different acquisition
functions so there are a lot of
acquisition functions there are actually
i mean more than i can count people are
coming up with new ones every day new
ones that maximize some slightly
different balance of exploration
exploitation or leverage some slightly
specific information that only exists in
one domain or another but the point is
different acquisition functions will
tell you to search different places
sometimes only a little bit different
sometimes if you have this black
acquisition function here all the way to
the side maybe you want to do that
so
different things can happen based on how
you choose to power your sequential
decision making process
and in particular the relationship
between the model that you choose and
the acquisition function can even be
complicated here again i've got three
different models all fit to in this case
i sort of did a little bit more crazy
data it's the same data but higher
variance so if i chose higher variance
in my model perhaps and you can see
different points that i might want to
sample based on each of these outcomes
because each of these has different
models
so
the model can have a big impact on
things in addition to that the
acquisition function can have a big
impact on things
that can mean that the choice of these
things can be scary i'm not going to lie
let's go through a little bit of
bayesian optimization in python right
now and in particular take a look at the
idea that hey
i've got my function
that i'm trying to study but of course i
can only sample it at a very small
number of points in particular let's say
these one two three four five points so
far
i'm going to use these one two three
four five points to ask where is the
next best place to sample and that's
going to be a function of the model that
i fit which is sort of roughly
represented here you see it's not a very
great model yet
it might be eventually
and i'm going to use that to power my
optimization process let's pop back into
our notebooks right now
and in particular i've got the same very
basic stuff again nothing nothing real
crazy doing here you don't need the
crazy stuff just to get the ball rolling
uh same uh object i've imported here i
added a couple extra things that i need
for the basin optimization and now i've
defined
a quantity called expected improvement
expected improvement is the classic
powerhouse of bayesian optimization you
do not need to use expected improvement
there are a lot of different options but
expected improvement has powered
more experiments than i could count in
the world everyone starts with expected
improvement and there's a reason for
that
it works
it's not any more complicated than that
expected improvement is really powerful
does that mean that it's the best for
all situations not even close does that
mean that it's even better than some
standard tools that exist in other
circumstances
no i think there are other things that
are even better i think knowledge
grading is probably better there's a
variant of expect improvement called
noisy expected improvement that i think
is probably better in most circumstances
but those are often much more
computationally expensive to execute and
also significantly more complicated to
understand and implement whereas
expected improvement is literally just
right here that's it that's the whole
thing
super duper tiny i take the posterior of
my gaussian process the posterior mean i
take the posterior variance
i compute a little extra z-score sort of
because of course we're talking about
normal random variables here take a
z-score
and then this is it that's the whole
it's so easy and that's why people love
it it's just so easy to look at so easy
to debug the gradient of it i didn't do
gradient optimization here but if you do
gradients of it gradient's not even any
more complicated than this you have to
throw in the gradient of the variance
and the mean obviously but
it's really really really simple and
that's why people love it and that's why
it's so popular and we're about to see
right now that even though it's really
simple
uh it still works just kind of works so
here i've again chosen some hyper
parameters for my gaussian process uh
again you could choose these any way you
want or you could fit them at each step
and we'll show that down below
and i've evaluated the expected
improvement all over the domain for
plotting purposes
and then what i've done in order to find
the max expected improvement in each
step is literally i've just evaluated a
bunch of random points took a bunch of
random points whichever one had the
highest expected improvement that's what
i took which is totally reasonable to do
because i have a small dimensional space
and because expected improvement is very
easy to vectorize
in general you should definitely do
something much smarter than this you
should do
some sort of gradient based optimization
breath it probably prefaced by some
amount of differential evolution or
maybe cmaes if you have a pure
um
continuous domain if you are looking for
a tool to use uh to do gradient free
optimization i absolutely would say
never grad again it's a facebook tool
never grad is an amazing tool definitely
use that
and i also would say
to do gradient based optimization
honestly
anything you do even just basic atom is
fine it'll work fine it might in my
opinion in my experience it usually
works fine and here you can see the the
process of the iteration i'm going to
expand this out and show you step by
step here five points this was the next
point we wanted now i've sampled at that
point that appears down here
i fit a new model it doesn't look all
that different from the other model
ironically so now okay but the but the
expected improvement at that point has
dropped considerably because i've
already sampled there so now i'm saying
okay i should sample here i sample there
oh hey my model is getting a little more
interesting
now
expected improvement says the sample
there i sample it okay hey hey a little
bit more interesting i keep going
through this process wherever is the
highest expected improvement i sample
and i go on and on and on like that here
it said try and sample here not because
it necessarily thought it was a great
value
but because it thought that it had a
very high variance if i said variance it
has a high chance for improvement which
means a high potential expected
improvement there but it turns out it
was kind of bad it samples here maybe
samples there okay all right i'm
sampling and as you can see as we go
along here
the samples do tend to be sort of
clustered around the good points but
scattered out there as needed based on
again what the model hyper parameters
are
and as you can see when you look at this
model this is not a great model of this
function right
but what it is is a good model around
the optimum
and that is how bayesian optimization
and all these sample efficient methods
work
they do not need to produce good models
when you are sampling when you are
trying to be sample efficient you do not
need
good models what you need is the right
data and if you use even a bad model in
the right way in this case through
expected improvement it can still power
your optimization process now in 2d
you could use an okay you could use a
good model and still find the option
because it doesn't matter because 2d is
very easy to talk about
but if we're talking about 10 11 12
dimensions here and you want to get the
optimum in 100 points you need to very
quickly throw away bad parts of the
domain and not try and build models in
bad parts of the domain and that is the
power of bayesian optimization and in
particular bayesian optimization using
expected improvement
below i show
uh quick examples of how to do this with
bow torch now here i've gone through and
done and you know what i'm even gonna
add this note here if you are not
interested in doing the bo yourself
but just want to
have something run it for you
use facebook's
axe so i put the link to acts in the
other um
the other notebook the calcium process
notebook ax is the tool that facebook
uses to simplify the interface if you
actually want to do the bo yourself
power it yourself this is how you do it
you run this loop you import all these
bo things and in particular you fit your
g g pi torch model at each step along
the way
and you evaluate expected improvement
using their expected improvement
acquisition function so they have a
separate one which takes in the gaussian
process and other information that is
required but it's the same loop as it
was before
i fit my model
which i've i fit up here and fit it down
here
i create my expected improvement
evaluation tool and then i optimize it
above i optimize it by taking a bunch of
random points they optimize it much more
intelligently than that and you can see
it's the exact same process and you end
up with the same uh scattering of points
right near the thing there i also show
the same thing for scikit optimize it's
a little harder to extract piecewise
information out from scikit optimize so
i just show the final outcome here which
is called very easily right here i show
the same thing with optuna again a
really cool tool out of the people from
preferred networks uh that
prints out a lot of information that
happens and then they run the same thing
they get you your good values
um
i know we're running up a little bit
against the clock here i see that it's 1
45 already and i'd like to be done about
10 minutes from now so um i am going to
pop back over to the top
and say that there are these other
sequential decision making topics
model building
viable outcomes integration model
parameterization
and in particular
i have here a notebook that creates this
gif
for us and i'll open up to the slideshow
right now to show this gif to show that
active learning optimization and search
all are similar in that they are all
iterative but they're trying to
accomplish very different goals active
learning is literally trying to poke
around the domain in some way that the
points are spaced out well enough to
learn about the function we're trying to
study
optimization is trying to just find the
optimum which is why we're kind of end
up targeting this main region over here
active surge on the other hand is trying
to find
suitably high values in this case i just
defined suitably high as above a
threshold 0.8 i think and you see it's
just kind of jamming points all up in
this region once it finds a happy region
that's what search does it jams things
up in that region
the notebook in order to follow this
along is available up there but i am not
going to run that right now i am going
to go right to using sig up because
that's what i want to do for my last 10
minutes because i am from sigot i think
cyclops is an amazing tool and the
reason i think cigarettes is an amazing
tool is that because while
i think that everything i've shown thus
far is cool in reality basic
optimization could do so many more
amazing things mixed parameters i'm
talking categorical integer continuous
and maybe conditional parameters in
there if you want constraints i'm
talking metric constraints and parameter
constraints multi-objective optimization
parallelism failures i know i wrote the
word failures there i guess i deleted it
all the stuff all the stuff you want to
be able to do with bayesian optimization
you can do that you absolutely can do
that the literature is out there if you
want to read it
but
sig opt has been designed to box all
that stuff up and host the computational
elements of this for you on our platform
in order to allow you to do your
sequential optimization and search
process without having to think about
things cop was founded in 2015 acquired
by intel in 2020
and is free to use for everyone in the
public right now thanks to the
generosity of intel um i say here it's
on a limited account it's a pretty
generous account if you need more you
call me and we'll work it out in
addition to that it has expanded use of
all the cool functionality for academics
again if you need more talk to me let's
work it out i want to get you uh stuff
to make cool stuff happen because that
is that is what i am most interested in
sigup works exactly the way that we're
talking about here it is this uh
sequential decision making loop i have
left this up because i told you guys i
am a corporate sellout i have to put
this slide in one slide of every talk i
give but in reality yes sig opt is a
really cool tool uh you tell us what
kind of problem you're interested in
solving we give you configurations to
test you test those configurations here
this is obviously specifically talking
about tuning a machine learning model
let's say things like your learning
rates or drop out your momentum
parameters we can help you tune that we
tell you what to do you tell us how it
performed and this loop is this
sequential decision making loop
sig up functionality
is
uh meant to be very abstract so you
don't have to concern yourself with any
of this gaussian processes bayesian
optimization stuff at all all right we
hide all of that from you in order to
get started on sigopd and and these
slides will be available to use you'll
be able to follow this up sign up for
free right now grab an api token you are
going to need your api token in general
we tell people to run sig up config i'm
going to run through a notebook where
you actually can avoid doing that but in
general running stay up config is
definitely the right thing to do
um
in sight every optimization the word we
use for optimization is experiment
function evaluations are called runs
though runs also encapsulate other meta
information about the function
evaluation
parameters are suggested by cig up so
those are your x values as we saw before
x1 x2 and metrics are reported back to
zig out those are your y values
and here now we're going to pop over to
our sig opt demo here
uh and you see here i'm i'm doing some
standard very basic imports this one i
actually am going to run what the heck i
hope it works we'll see
um
so we're gonna do uh uh standard stuff
uh this or the standard set of con stick
up config actions you would use i'm not
gonna use that now i'm gonna use the
other one it doesn't matter again uh in
general it is a super bad thing to do to
put your sig opt api token uh right here
uh in your code so don't do that don't
worry i'm going to roll this token as
soon as this topic is over but i made
sure to give myself a token that fingers
crossed will actually work
um
in general what you should do is you
should store this as an environment
variable and then you won't need any of
this at all so you got to just pick it
up for your environment so that way you
don't share it with other people
accidentally
um
here's a function evaluation uh this is
the exact same function we were studying
before i've tossed in that threshold we
were using before as i mentioned for
that search problem point a5
here we go
sig opt create experiment this is how
you tell sig ups what problem you're
trying to solve and in particular i have
the exact problem we were talking about
before i'll pull it up again
uh from zero to one in two dimensions
that is the problem i'm trying to solve
right here i need to tell sig op that i
need to tell singap what optic metric
i'm trying to optimize uh in this case
metrics just y it doesn't have to be a
fancy name you can make it a fancy name
and we will in a second but it just has
to be a name it says i don't care what
it is
um tell it if you want to maximize or
minimize and in this case optimize of
course you're trying to optimize it
although we'll talk about other options
in a second i gave us a budget of 25
uh iterations and we're going to see how
well we can do in 25 iterations here
i've created the experiment
view it on the dashboard let's pull that
up right now i have to punch in my
password of course i do please don't
steal my password internet
all right i hope i know my password now
that i think about it
there we go all right very good
so here is the uh experiment that i have
just created right now and all of you of
course can do the same thing probably
with a different as i mentioned token
uh frankie function uh you can watch
this experiment progress and i'm about
to click the button to do that but
before i do that i'll rewind for a
second and show that uh inside sig opt
you pull open your api tokens by
clicking here you also can see all the
various orgs and teams that you're a
part of
um you don't have that butt inside
edmond because you people are not site
admins
and you can check the various projects
and experiments that you're a part of
here here you can see some experiments
that i ran earlier to confirm that all
of these things that i've written up
actually worked correctly uh but you
could see these experiments and in
particular you could share these with
other members of your team or even
externally you have the ability to
share and experiment with anybody
in the world even without giving them uh
access to your account which i like
so uh we're going to watch this execute
i'm going to go down here and i'm going
to run a loop
where i ask sig opt for a next set of
parameters to test what is the next
thing i should run
and um i just noticed that my headset
just died for some reason not sure why
um
and um hopefully all of you can still
hear me i think you can and um in
addition to that we are going to report
back to sig ops run dot log metric and
that run dot log metric is going to tell
sigop how this turned out i'm going to
start this up right now and there we can
see that as things are running we are
going to be able to view it on the
dashboard i've added here this statement
time dot sleep 2. uh in reality you
wouldn't do this i'm doing this just to
simulate what something actually looks
like so that we can pop over here and
actually monitor things as it's going
along and there we can see as things are
going long we can watch how long various
runs are taking of course they're all
going to take roughly the same amount of
time here and this is the progress of
the experiments so far as we creep along
one two three four five this will update
every 30 seconds i think um
and you will you will see this graph
continue to update and you also have the
ability to click into the analysis page
as more updated version of this graph
and surveys some of the information
that's available in particular for this
this example that's 2d you can see the
sampling of the points and and
unsurprisingly the clustering of the
points around where the optimum is there
and
i am going to
pop back over to the summary
and we can see here we're 18 deep out of
25 things are progressing in reality
though i know what the answer is for
this particular problem it is like 1.219
i have the ability to click on the best
observation and it'll pull me up to a
page that is specific to that run so if
i just want to share this information
with other people i have the ability to
do so
click back over here and you can see we
are done 25 out of 25. it says no
failures up here no failed observations
unsurprising because we didn't allow
ourselves to report any failures
um i'm just gonna very quickly here
confirm just want to confirm that we can
still uh
hear me even though my headset just died
if somebody if something happens write a
note to me so that i can hear it um and
and that's how you run sig up and you'll
notice here there's absolutely no
bayesian optimization it all gets run on
sale outside it all gets organized on
sig upside and you do not need to care
about those things
and uh in addition to that i have the
ability to pull the data
plot the outcome and this of course
looks very very very similar to what we
were seeing a second ago
as we saw the points scattered around
but sigup is doing all the smart stuff
around as i mentioned before fitting the
gaussian process
i'll run uh one more type of experiment
now we mentioned before this idea of a
search experiment where i'm going to set
a threshold here i'm telling sigup what
that threshold is
and then i'm going to run this and this
is going to give me
a different set of information i'll let
that run and while that's running i'll
pop back to a completed version of this
which i hope is this i think it is
um
[Music]
and we can see here that uh in fact
these points end up being a good deal
more spread out than they were for the
pure optimization problem and we also
see some of these points grayed out in
this particular situation the reason
they're grayed out is because they don't
satisfy the threshold we set a threshold
for ourselves of 0.85 and our goal was
to find a bunch of points higher than
0.85 that are somehow spread out
throughout the domain and that's what we
ended up doing and if we click into the
currently running experiment hopefully
we see that it's doing uh exactly that
well just so happened the first point
happened to be a good point but in
general they won't be that's what we're
seeing here and again we're having
points spread out that are all high
performing points which can be really
useful to learn about high performing
regions
of the domain at this point i will
kill this
and
i will
mention and i won't bother to run it
because they'll take a second but um
you can also run
um
a
optimization or search on multiple
metrics you can run search on actually
like
four metrics
um but uh in general i i i up to
actually up to six but in general if
you're going to do optimization which is
to say multimetric stuff
uh you should probably be doing that in
my opinion on on two and that you can
actually do in a sample efficient
fashion which again i'll pull up one of
the completed experiments here
to show what the impact of the pareto
frontier is
um and uh this pareto frontier here is
obviously only an estimated pareto
frontier uh but it is a pretty good
approximation to what's going on right
now uh and in particular i see someone
has a question i will i will answer that
in just a second
uh in particular um the problem we're
solving here is a sort of fun problem
that i like to consider often which is
okay i'm going to pretend i have the
global max that i found from some
previous experiment here
given that i have the global max how can
i find points that are high performing
but are kind of
far away from the global max
and that's a problem that can be solved
sort of with this multi-metric concept
here
and when i do that the outcome looks
like looks like this basically which is
okay i have my optimum but i'm
scattering points out around from the
optimum because i'm trying to get away
from the optimum so so that's this
region right here where i'm at the
optimum and i'm trying to walk away and
then as i get further away i try and
search this region a little bit more
this region a little bit more and then i
end up in this region and these are the
different parts of the pareto frontier
that we end up seeing observed here and
that we can visualize here uh sig out
uh with that i will uh wrap it there's
one other experiment that i sort of had
to show here which was a metric
constraint style experiment so suppose
i'm requiring sig up to only find
answers outside of this circle
i have the ability to do so by saying uh
please don't search inside this circle
and and reporting that to sigops by
saying set the distance from the global
max to be at least in this case point
three
and that turns to be okay i find this
answer instead and then it finds that
answer and it's happy so
with that i am going to pop back to my
slides and pop down to the
references slides here's some good
references on gps questions and i see a
question
uh rebecca would you mind uh trying to
talk right now so that i can hear you
sure do you hear me
see that is interesting i cannot hear
you right now so i'm going to stop
sharing my slides i'm going to figure
out why that is
i see why that could you try talking now
yeah do you hear me
well okay maybe i don't understand how
my computer works uh that is fine people
type to me i can talk and type i'm going
to answer this question and then i will
wrap it um
so uh how to sync up compared to optuna
first off optune is a really cool tool i
have a couple friends that preferred
network who built opportunist otorosano
the
and also masahiro nomura uh all of whom
are really awesome people doing really
amazing work
a tuna is a great tool but it is powered
by a different mechanism than sigopt is
opptune is primarily at to this point i
think almost exclusively powered by the
the tree of parson estimators mechanism
and uh in particular the tpe mechanism
is great for quick scaling and fast
uh iteration so minimizing the amount of
computation that's going on which is
really nice if you're taking care of the
computation uh if cigox is taking care
of the computation it matters a little
bit less and in general i think most
people would probably agree if somebody
disagrees uh but i'm happy to listen to
it but i think most people would
probably agree that uh gaussian
processes are significantly more power
you're part of an estimator's
just gonna see if mechanism able to fix
this now uh so so that is why i think um
optuna is a very easy to use tool and
like i said i gave you i gave you the
exact instructions on how to use it i
guess it's a fantastic tool i do think
stick up is going to be more powerful
especially in the multi-metric
situations especially in very sample
efficient situations tree of partisan
estimators mechanism the tree element
was designed to scale to tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
observations but if you're only doing
40 observations you're not getting the
benefit from it but you are paying the
penalty of using a weaker modeling tool
than a gaussian process uh but like i
said i still think optune is a really
cool tool and i definitely definitely
recommend checking it out but i also
definitely recommend checking sigot out
because we allow it to uh abstract out
some of these advanced functionality
including for instance metric
constraints which can be very difficult
to implement but that i think we handle
very effectively uh rebecca or yes
sherry absolutely happy too happy two
weeks
yeah i just put on the transcription i
don't know how my damn
you can't hear us maybe you can see the
words i don't know the transcription
that i'm saying oh wait wait oh now i
can hear now i can hear perfect very
good okay there we are very good very
good
uh yeah anyone can feel free to unmute
and ask a question or ask in the chat
apologies for taking so taking so long
there on the on the talk but i'm i'm
really glad we got to cover all of that
and i i promised the links i here's the
link sorry all right i think you already
maybe already shared the link yeah you
already oh you shared the link let me
show the link to the slides too
and um
i also will
uh roll my token so that nobody creates
a million experiments on my token
uh hopefully that works and i'm gonna
pull my token out right now
all right any anything else anything
else
okay maybe we'll call it again thank you
for such a engaging talk michael
perfect
yeah
we just as a reminder we usually have
our
pi data meetings on the fourth thursday
of the month
so stay tuned we'll be posting on
meetups soon
[Music]
bye everyone
take care everyone thank you very much
again